We are able to change so many things
that were impossible before,
and it's only the beginning.
That's my view of this world.
And I'm excited every day.
And that's what I love about my
again, actually what I do.
Zvi Guterman,
thank you for being on my show
20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
Very well, thank you.
Pleasure to be here.
Thank you for taking time
out of your busy day to be here.
You're coming from my favorite industry.
And I'm excited talk about cyber,
about cloud.
But even more than those two,
I'm excited to talk about
the entrepreneurial journey
of a serial entrepreneur
that is now 14 years
into the making of CloudShare,
an incredible company
in the cloud space
with so many incredible customers.
But besides cloud share,
you also have some incredible experience,
like a lecturing and advising groups
like Innovation Endeavors,
and being on the board of companies.
So, all around,
just an incredible trajectory.
Zvi, who are you?
How do you get started
with computer science?
And what is really your passion
with what you're doing?
So, I started my career actually,
because I love technology.
Like many others, as a teenager,
I was playing with computers
in the early days.
So, I was born in the 70s,
early 70s.
'73 to be accurate.
And as I was growing,
we got the first computers to Israel,
ZX Spectrum at that time,
Atari, and later the PC.
And it was amazing.
And it was, again, I remember
the fact that you can write code
and do something,
play games and you can start
having this device do things for you.
And I think we were lucky
and I'm fortunate
to be able to witness that.
And I say to many people
that we're fortunate
we are in the middle
of a second industrial revolution
where the computer is changing.
We, sometimes we say,
software eating the world.
But I think we,
in the good sense, hopefully,
we are able to change so many things
that were impossible before.
And it's only the beginning.
That's my view of this world.
And I'm excited every day.
And that's what I love
about my, again actually what I do
is that we learn, we try new things,
we change the world a little bit,
and it's wonderful to do that.
Wonderful.
Take me back to your childhood
when you're witnessing this change.
Because I am assuming
that most kids around you
aren't necessarily as excited
or as infatuated with this technology
as you are, correct me if I'm wrong.
But what was that experience really like?
For me, I should add that
I wasn't good enough in basketball
and soccer.
So, I guess it's always that you compensate.
I love it.
So, I was very good
with math and computer science then.
And again, it was clear that
you could do things.
And again, as I said, I wasn't so good,
I enjoyed playing basketball
and I'm relatively tall,
but I wasn't good enough.
I was a swimmer in high school,
semiprofessional.
And I understood very quickly that
I want to be the best swimmer
in all the best athletes in any way.
And I was really good in math
and computer science, physics.
And it was the early days
of computer science.
And it was so exciting.
So, I really loved it.
My mother really wanted me
to go to med school,
and was encouraging and pushing.
And computer science was a new thing.
So, it wasn't very established
and they actually weren't aware
that I'm going to study that.
But I really had the passion
and they supported me.
And then one thing led to the other.
Like I finish my bachelor,
I did my master,
and then I did my PhD.
And it was, I kept finding new things.
And then a friend told me,
"Hey, let's start the company together."
And that turned into my
security company.
And I think,
again, in many ways, you know,
I'll say something maybe
for other people
that may be listening or watching this,
I think we we're fortunate
that in a way,
you know, we sometimes,
some of us look super small
to the big heroes.
But I'll say about myself,
I think we, a lot of things
are just timing.
And it's such a wonderful opportunity,
the world is changing
and you are in the right spot.
So, it's not that we are smarter
than other people that,
but in many cases just we were
in the right time
in this wave of innovation.
We understood it
and many of us are using it
and developing interesting applications.
And that's actually maybe
interconnected to other things
that I know that you are talking
in interesting many people,
that's still the motivation for me.
If you ask me what is like,
where do I want to go next
with my company
and other companies
if I'm looking and joining
on the board level or investor,
is finding innovation.
Finding something that is not trivial,
that software can improve.
And we see a lot of innovation
around health, around enterprise IT
that keep improving our work.
And that's what gets me excited.
I love that.
And now, correct me if I'm wrong
but the timeline that
I'm looking at right here
says that you are doing your PhD
from 2004 to 2008,
but you were the CTO of Safend
from 2003 to 2006.
So, you were basically starting
and sold the company
while you were doing your PhD
in the Hebrew University, correct?
Yes.
And I won't to recommend it to others.
It's not the best path. And we actually,
so, you can do better.
Yeah. It's not the best path
Like, I feel that
I didn't contribute enough to Safend.
And I would encourage
the other people to focus
on one thing and try to do that
all hearted.
But yes, I was,
I really enjoyed the academic world.
And I found the research
actually on security in crypto.
And even on that side,
I really was focusing
on how to bridge
the complex meth crypto world
and the real world
and find real solutions
to these problems.
No no no. Not at all.
Do me a favor, because you know,
when I'm looking at
a lot of the people of my age,
not necessarily coming out of units
like the 8200 or 81,
but around the world
that are studying computer science.
And if I look at the things
that they're really excited about
in the companies that early,
that early entrepreneurs,
young entrepreneurs are creating,
they're not usually in the crypto world,
in the cybersecurity world.
They're in like
the more sexier consumer world.
Can you give me
a little bit of insight into
what is so exciting to you
and so appealing to you
about the complex math,
cryptography, cloud based solutions
that you've been working on
for these decades?
Sure. By the way,
I was asking is your picture disappeared.
Maybe its a Zoom challenges
So, two things.
And I say these are two areas
that maybe I should talk about.
One is actually in my career,
I actually dealt more
with B2B enterprise businesses
that you mentioned about
young founders,
talking about the consumer ideas, etc.
So, on that side,
I usually, when I meet
young entrepreneurs,
I would say two things.
One, even on the financial aspect,
usually a B2B startups
are 10 times more successful
in the end result, more rewarding.
And about 100 times less competitive.
Really?
And usually, again,
if you come with a new Twitter,
usually you'll find again
in the numbers the multiplies,
and let's say if I'm wrong,
only 10 times.
So, usually it's natural
that we come more with the consumer idea
because we are all consumers. Right?
But actually,
what I would encourage someone,
take a step back,
don't focus on your,
how you can improve Twitter a little bit.
But, hey, look at the industry
and go find a CIO
that work for oil and gas
and ask to join him for a day
or maybe for a week.
Do an internship.
And see what kind
of challenges they face.
You'll be amazed
that people are dealing with multi, tens
and hundreds of billions of markets
and problems that are just
far away from you.
Let's talk about today, covid-19.
I have a good friend.
She works for Pfizer
and she shared with me
just the complexity of the FDA system.
It's a software system
that is dealing with the experiments.
And now, and actually,
she talked with me about it
three years ago.
And she kept talking to me
you know, that's a place for innovation.
So, every founder that came to me
I said, "Go, speak with her.
This is her domain."
You're targeting 20 companies,
but that's an important area.
And now this is it, you came well,
this is so important.
People are dealing with that daily.
But that's one example.
That's my view,
that usually for us,
again, we used to think as consumers,
but definitely it's when we are young.
But actually,
the enterprise market is big, interesting
and usually somewhat easier
and more rewarding.
Again, if you're passionate,
of course, if your are passionate
for something, go with it.
But just one observation, it's interesting.
Back to your question on crypto.
What I found about crypto,
which I think is amazing
and unique to that domain,
is that actually crypto
is the junction of crossroads
of many things.
One complex math.
Like complexity and combinatorics
and a lot of really interesting things.
Second, it's something that if you,
I did my PhD in computer science,
you're always in areas
that are semi theoretical.
And then people are doing things
that are, you're not sure how practical are.
Crypto, is one of the most
practical things we deal with.
So, the fact that crypto
has an amazing influence
on Second World War,
I think when you think about the enigma
and into the what we are using now
and the security challenges
that Zoom had and many things.
So, it's super practical,
very interesting on the academic level.
And so many problems are still,
are still open
and have room to walk around.
So, I think for young researchers
and young entrepreneurs,
there's a lot to do.
And we still face
a lot of challenges.
And I'll give you maybe, one example
I think that we witnessed in the last,
we witnessed in the last year is
cyber war games.
Again, something that I was working
in the last year.
It's a new domain that's really growing.
And it's so impressive to see
a lot of innovation.
So, cyber war games, in short,
you're trying to replicate
and create scenarios
that will train people
how to react in real time
and how to do better.
And it goes from something very simple.
For example, there's a very nice company
that, again, the most dangerous element
in security is us, human being.
Because we do human mistakes.
And the biggest mistake
is people phishing emails
that you press the wrong link
and you start a wire transfer
or you were pull a wire transfer
by mistake and etc.
There is a very nice company
that is just dealing with that element.
And actually, if you are the corporate,
let's say, again,
Coke, and you buy their service,
they start sending phishing emails
to your IPO, maybe more than that,
to your finance, etc.
And they collect the data, compress that,
and they come to you and say,
you know what, here are 10 people,
maybe you should better educate them
because they are unaware.
I love that.
That's amazing.
And it's a wonderful, wonderful solution.
So, simple and nice.
And I love this kind of elegant solutions
then they are wire
and they can charge
$2 per user per month,
whatever the metric is.
And so nice.
And you don't even need,
like, complex crypto for that.
You see a lot of the innovation
these days around multiparty computation.
This is actually one of the most
advanced things in crypto.
A lot of research in recent years around
how we break a secret that,
and how we between
stuff on secret sharing
that we kind of, we break a secret
between five people
that any three of them together
can open the safe,
but one or two together
cannot do anything.
Or how do we take something
very complex and very important
and we distribute it
between different computers
and allow each of them
to do a slow computation.
Well actually, if you break
into one of them,
you will not learn anything
about the secret.
Let's say you calculate
some insurance ratio,
whatever that is classified or whatever,
or has privacy issues.
So, you want if someone breaks
into a computer,
the secrets will not be revealed.
So, there's a lot
of interesting innovation.
It's also very challenging.
And I should say also,
on the other hand,
entrepreneurs should be worried
or should consider at least
not to do a Me Too,
kind of again using Me Too,
but in another context startup.
Because the other challenge
that we see in security,
we see a lot of companies
that are somewhat
with the bigger need for security
doing very similar solutions.
So you see,
like a lot of new firewalled companies.
They don't call themselves,
they do targeted attacks
and they only analyze the yellow packets
that are going outside them.
So, I would encourage entrepreneurs
to be careful from going that way
because that's really risky place.
And going back to
the beginning of the conversation
where you mentioned about innovation.
And that's at the end,
what's most exciting,
what's most appealing,
perhaps to you as a board member
and an investor.
But really, that's also what's really
warms the heart and makes somebody,
I think, truly passionate
and feel innovative.
So, talking about innovation,
I think that's a perfect segue.
We have just a short amount of time
but I'd love to hear a little bit
of a 14 year journey through CloudShare.
First and foremost,
what is it like running a company
for 14 years?
I don't think many entrepreneurs
get to have that privilege.
Yeah. It's like [--],
you should multiply that by something.
Yeah.
It's definitely a long journey.
And I should say, and also again,
for hopefully for entrepreneurs
that listening to that
and thinking about the beginning
of their journey,
one, I did a lot of mistakes.
And people should understand
it's a long journey.
On average, it's 10 years
And you should find out,
first, actually,
if you are in the right room
and I think one of the things
that happened in the last 20 years
change definitely,
that it's easier to be an entrepreneur
and which is great, right.
We see a lot of accelerators
and a lot of programs
that actually help you stuff
and I'm the last to judge
but the first question
I'm asking entrepreneurs,
just make sure that
you are in the right room,
that you're doing the right thing.
Because it looks glamorous
and you may think
that I'm just celebrating
between cocktail parties
and you see my name
on all sorts of press releases.
But the reality is that
it's really hard work.
And there are a lot of fires
when you manage people.
You need to hire, you to grow.
Sometimes, things are not working.
And it's a long journey.
And first thing you need to be ready
and love it.
And again, for myself,
I found out throughout the years
that I'm really excited
about working with people,
setting the strategy,
solving all of these challenges.
14 years is a long period
and definitely, the company
change itself along the way.
We started actually
we called the ourselves IT structure
when we started the company.
And it was all around IT
and the need to configure
virtual machines
where you look 14 years after
we talk about
business acceleration cloud.
We try with our platform
to help people do more business
and allow them to grow their business
and use the experience
that head on experience
of their software in the cloud.
So, we actually help
training organizations
and serve organization
to provide hands on experience.
And it was a complete journey.
Other things, we raised a lot of money.
Raised over $30 million from VC's.
We almost sold the company
at least once.
We really did due diligence
for a three hundred million dollar deal
that didn't work out.
I didn't do very well
on the board level.
I did many mistakes.
And the board encouraged or reinforced
and brought the very seasoned CEO.
It almost killed the company.
So, I witnessed a lot of things.
Then we did the management buyout.
The last five years we already
[--] and going year over year
with nice multiplier.
It's definitely challenging.
I think again, for me,
I found out
that that's really exciting as well.
But it has a lot of challenges.
And as you mentioned,
definitely software,
14 years it's like 100 years.
Like the architecture
of the software is so different, etc.
I can't even imagine.
One of the things that
we're going to have to leave
to the next episode
that we'll do one day
is how to remain innovative
in a 14-year period.
And you're mentioning that in software,
it's like a 100 years.
And I'm looking at, you know,
I am looking at companies
that I got a chance to be involved in.
And, for example,
the Israeli Defense Force,
the softwares that I built
in 2014 and 2015,
I already had to refactor.
And in 2016, we had to kill
and create a new software
because the world has changed already.
So, I can empathize a lot
with this problem.
And we'll have to wait that
for the next episode.
But Zvi, I want to thank you
for being so generous with your time.
Unfortunately,
I called the show 20 Minutes Leaders
I should have called it
30 minute leaders.
But I have to ask you
the most important question,
which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Hopefully, this junction of product,
technology and business
I love that.
Probably that's what I learned,
that I'm really excited about doing.
I started my career with that
on the technology side.
And all the time
I know that's what actually
where I try to accelerate
and excel and drive results.
Zvi, we thank you for sharing with me
your passion, your curiosity.
I gained so much inspiration from it.
Thank you very much.
Toda raba.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Thank you, Michael. Happy to be here.